This is Station eleven recorded with faith.
Bandler and Karen Craig Tuesday the twelfth of August one nine hundred ninety seven in approximately ten seconds time.
Faced you just want to pick up from where we left off.
Yes there was I got to finish off a little about the Aboriginal Australia and finish it.
As I told you in the beginning the goal was to work for the evolution of the New South Wales Aboriginal welfare.
That was Polls here. Well we campaigned against the board for thirteen years. No stop.
And Tony just this tiny group of people lived and breathed the work of a fellowship.
And as one of the Aboriginal person came brindle. Said. I've never met a group of people like this.
I was strange to me they didn't talk about Jesus and I didn't talk about this
and all those things that all the other organizations talked about you know getting people to be Christians.
So full of.
Funny little group of people who got together even in the middle of winter in a definitely old office there in
Chinatown and thank you got stuck into the government. And I made positive.
And well the government doesn't like money so that must be all right.
But he could never understand us and he said to me one day earlier you were involved in this doesn't. To you.
Running down the running all over the place and kicking up a fuss. He says we like it. Get out of the.
Others get out of it and down there in that little office the great great woman. Jack and you know. Lenin mono fox.
Bird Charlie Leo and paying. Us about it. When we took the state government on.
Well Ken was amazed he couldn't understand he says and he looked a bit Graffy at times you know a lot.
I didn't think you'd get anywhere. Well the fellowship worked very hard.
First of all like challenge the ball or challenge the government the the.
The lack of one right which the Aborigines were confronted with and that was the right to go into premises.
Where alcohol was so hold
and as a result of these men he suffered very much so because women in particular who were bringing their sick children
from the waist in the south and.
Would travel by train and these trains were very slow
and so they would have to sit on the railway station because they wouldn't be permitted to have a room in a local pub.
And the children would have to sit through that often in the winter.
So apart from the fact that they were DID NOT a right great. People were suffering help.
So we fought that section and if they have New South Wales. And we had it apart. And then it was so time.
You know like sixty like sixty.
Where there are ten sixteen zero on the board was abolished
and what did the fellowship do they closed the organization. No one was there.
To carve a career out of it for themselves and that had happened very much.
And some of the Aboriginal charities that were.
People quite got you know and they were paid a salary to look after the blacks you see
and we didn't have people like that in the fellowship. So I want to make their point that immediately we reached.
We close the organization. And that was in one nine hundred sixty. Now in nineteen fifty seven.
The Federal Council was formed of child Dr Charles do good. And in many ways the work was being duplicated.
Like housing education.
Not so much into health but into equal employment and both organizations were doing very much the same work.
It was a good thing in a way that the Fellowship closed.
Because those skills and all of that experience then could be turned into the federal body which was formed.
And I mentioned earlier.
That he felt the motion was moved to the third or fourth conference or second conference of the federal.
That it should be become responsible for the circulation of the petition for the referendum.
And that was so then the petition began to become. The responsibility of the Federal Council. I would see.
The people of Melbourne. And the people of Sydney.
Were the leaders in that that is not in that campaign but that is not to say that the people who Western Australia
and Queensland didn't pull the white they did but they didn't have the facilities that we had
and I did not they did they have the people.
On a broad level to pull the churches who were pulling this from us but we were able to do that in Melbourne
and Sydney.
Now Jack Horner who for about I mean the secretary of fellowship had now you know on the executive of the Federal
Council and Jack is a very very dedicated dedicated and this and that the church had a duty here.
And he would not let up until they saw that duty
and it was a duty towards personal people that didn't have to do the charity. Well. Jack couldn't come.
And I do know that time and again conferences in Sydney. And he was bad to the bishops. And. They all knew him.
And fortunately we had among the Anglican bishops and reverend gentleman opposed
and as I mentioned earlier a friend called Rick.
Who took up a collection in the town hall for us
or one of the two people who did that come to call Drake was an open door. And the corridors of that. Drive.
And he wasn't going to have an admission charity.
The federal Constitution had to be changed and of course I thought it crazy. How do you read the law. Do you Richard.
You were a federal constitution. But he persisted and I cannot speak to. Honus dedication to and as well.
So the petition got off the ground in a big way on a national level.
Now I have touched on this because I remember saying how clean the house do all the meetings but during this time.
There were people like myself who. Were in a way becoming nationally and in fact during the campaign.
And this was also very involved with. And he and his wife invited me to go over and take some meeting.
And I had been to Perth before. But more for my pleasure. And I went to have campaigning.
And they wanted me with a local doctor who was the wife of one of the senators who was who would have me
and my stay with people. Not have to go out. Speak so they booked me to the Travelodge and Gerald Walsh.
Was just big becoming a journalist at the time and came to the travel hard to see me.
And I was sort of floating rate guy but he just made for myself and I was going out to dinner with friend.
But she came a knock tomato. So she came in and. They still kick them out.
And they certainly not allow him to places like that
and I think you should talk to some of those people who brought a few people picked me up or other
and took me to make some of the people who were suffering these indignity he said it was one thing to go out
and stand before the businessman or.
Business Women's luncheon or what have you personally it was necessary to take the people along with us.
And they should be informed of what we were on about.
So I went to a group of people my countrymen personally whether it was a public meeting or.
Which direction had organized and I talked about the need to hold this referendum.
While our models are well I've been talking to. A brick wall. They weren't interested in the least.
What about our houses. New jobs. What about all my people a sick then dying and. All of that you see me.
Serious problems while lying heavily on their shoulders
and you come here talking about changing the federal constitution should we change the federal constitution we want
these things now. And do you see it was at a time when the state still fully controlled the Aboriginal people.
And that had enough of their people had been flogged for their people had been jailed in the worst then people right in
the forty's for working in what am I talking about the federal constitution for.
And it was very difficult to convince the people what I refer him to do. That was a great lesson to me.
And so I think I can say with confidence.
That very few people comparatively speaking where involved in the referendum in the campaign.
We had those who were very enlightened in Melbourne and Sydney.
And perhaps a handful in the other states but that was about all those fires indigenous people. And.
Just before you tell you that Britain can human in the late fifty's you went to post was that in the beginning.
Into the sixty's into the sixty's that was well into the sixty's it was coming up close to sixty seven. Yeah.
But early in the sixty's the fellowship.
Decided that they should bring the Eversharp more a person
or people into it a lot of Aboriginal people in New South Wales but then had tremendous faith in the fellowship.
There wasn't another organisation going who would protect them from the. Who.
So I thought well I better go over to read for a few minutes into the hair and see if I get them to pull a white.
But Jack in June. Holder I think of us who sit well but if we're on a day.
Now I haven't talked about the dances over there and they were for both the Federal Council and the fellowship to try.
Well we had the Waterloo town hall. And we worked.
And then we had a fellowship monthly meeting to finalize the right range plans for the first day.
And who should turn up. And kid and he said listen you lot. What are you doing over there in my area. So you come.
Now we run a dance for our footballers and I'll go do your day.
What are we going to do to keep the bass on the first you see it. Incidentally it was black and white.
So I was furious with us so we come to him and. He said Oh OK.
You're on the dance on my mobile come up but we better have a look at his dances
and if I compare couldn't compare it with. We were highly organized you see. There was surely some a.
And she carried a good nineteen twenty nine. Surely necklace and surely what we need.
Is that we're not going to have any drunks in the home. Because they'd come out after ten o'clock.
After the pubs that close.
And it wasn't that they could actually get the growing from the pub
but they could get around the back as much as what it was illegal. So they'd come.
And surely would stand at the top of the stairway and anyone who misbehaved would get just one with a huge chip
and then go rolling down the stairs and she was like an eyebrow. Well. It was a bouncer. Absolutely.
She was a bouncer and then the shows were rip roaring success. With the money with footballers.
And we were a protection.
You see for the people because what normally happened would be the cops would come and her under them
but that doesn't mean that petty worked and.
So life began to appreciate this group of people all looking very trim and proper.
You know and I think glasses and hanging them and everyone like a glove so if you played so I had made afraid.
Of a person by the name of Barry Cohen. And Barry at that time was already the. Clothing shop in the park.
Thriving business to this very day. And this is going back an awful long time. And Barry said to me one day.
But so what can I do what can I do if I really want to do something.
It's terrible what they're doing to the Aboriginal people. I saw when I bury we're running these the.
And why didn't you come over and give us a hand. By then we had a roster you see of for people to go over to refer to.
Manager and. There is if you're sure of course I will.
Now I had also become very friendly with through his wife and I saw all the children growing up to three.
And at this time. Ray was hardly pregnant with the third one.
So we left her at her friend's place who was a friend who was on the executive of the fellowship and hounds
and I had a nice evening while we went over to read for.
Barry being a business man I said listen very Your job is to take the five bob at the door for shillings entrance.
So you sit here and I had trouble looking at. So you just walked at every shop as he always did.
Amy and I recall a lady had to make a move since yellow pullover on and I went with him he picked me up
and Jean gave him you know negation a few instructions about.
Taking the five bar and making sure that nobody got in for nothing. Well around about half past ten comes.
So I was a take and he says you fuckin white man. We're not paying you anymore I'm down my dad.
And Barry stood in the door the entrance to the States and he said Now you know where. This is you think you are.
I'm going in. Barry says no you're not. You're not and this went on and on and Barry wouldn't give an inch.
I will never forget it ever. All the others compiled. Barry and so are you. And Shirley is waiting at the top of that.
So he slips in behind a rambling hand Berry and shoots up I'm going to be turfed down again by Shirley's big.
Then one day one of the here leaders his wife was Piggy. Said. We need more people at the end.
I said you know I think they'd get a marvelous supper you know. All thrown in for. But I sent.
She says you know marking the return people come about.
We need them to come from apple green valley and black town and how do we do that. And she said to me I will call Joey.
If you type and later for me. Culturally to bring his. Contribution to the.
I didn't know who it was forty years fifty euro. Into a culturally must be something of a man.
So we talked to him later and she took it into his office from where he was calm to show it came with this band.
Where he couldn't like a drone we had to lock him in the kitchen.
And I remember standing kitchen door and the young girls were trying to push it back together.
With their little pieces of paper and pin so for autographs or what have you. We kept him there.
Until he came in and it was an eye opener. Now I understand they don't want to rock is about.
And why they go but he was a person who was loved by married women.
He was very much sort of but when he walked onto the plane just weighed completely.
One mad a lot of money that night because he wasn't letting everyone in.
And I didn't tell you that you almost threw us. Anyhow I had just had to remember.
And enriching evening so I had it lay with the people.
I was doing state and it was going to be held on the Thursday before Easter.
And I guess this would have been sixty five sixty six.
And there were a lot of people on the footpath you know you sort of walked and got to be there. What have you.
To pending work and came.
And I was just going to babble all of these people into the tube and Jack Horner went out
and the petty were going straight away. Then another man. There was a terrible fight out.
And we were a bit worried about these two blokes who getting into each other.
Look it just appeared like kill each other. And you're walked out and he started very badly and.
The respectable dances. If you want to fight. I'm to the park. And you wouldn't believe. Karen.
Those two black stopped and I went down into the park to finish the fight and Ken said
when I saw objects stand between the two men I thought they clearly.
They didn't and that was what the respect was like for the little group of people.
They knew who you were and I went away and they finished the fight in the park. And Carolyn.
These were rich experiences in my life I was brought. Where my mom never so much as put a finger on not even a smack.
If we did the wrong thing you should sit there and cry.
And their interest for it was very foreign to me extremely far and I couldn't as a standard.
And I guess that made me really great for China. What exactly for I wasn't quite sure. Certainly from our fundie.
Change for. The federal government to become responsible for the people on the house.
That there was also a need for a child. For the people to each other from each other and need for respect.
And the sort of people who came to their stances Was there a mixture of everybody in it mainly Aboriginal people coming.
Oh no. Why the Fellowship a point where there are sheep Yes and a few people who volunteered.
There were all those people fern Aboriginal people and I knocked on these dances there's nobody else.
And it was wonderful. Would get a whole lot of stuffed and aged to me in the way for a battle.
And the every two women would come into the kitchen and Microsoft. Always sandwiches and big parts of tea.
And it became a great social affair. It was a very important period. And I was greatly humbled that.
And it made me fully realize what a very potent piece of history was happening really.
People who are people who are thinking.
People will be beginning to think about those kinds of people in the work community who made up the fellowship
executive. The world that made me very few of the master spends ten or twelve we made security.
Then came brindle who was dedicated to the family and all that we were doing was one of the leaders in Redfern. And.
We'd get into Ken's house and Caroline Street. Posters for Ed you know.
I'm coming back into the fellowship because that was a very important thing. That happened.
The cops would just drive up to a person's house and arrest them for nothing.
Now they would they did this to Kane because what. And.
It would be two or three in the morning sometimes
and my wife would ring who want to come on the police have taken care and when you come to the station.
Me and I'd go and put houses. Few people now. And. Then there was a time when.
Young a personal person young man was shot. DETECTIVE. For breaking allegedly breaking into a chaos and pinching.
Cigarettes. And there was quite a disturbance in Redfern about this and great concern. And his mother.
Rang and said look this is happened. And came to the police station and.
What's the charge what if you knowing that you could ring up the fellowship if there was any trouble from.
The cops will tell you what. And I beat him out. They didn't arrest him.
But a detective got into him and I didn't care what anyone says positives that came got him to the detective as well.
Well the law of the short of it is that Kane was charged for bashing up a cop. On a fellowship moved in quickly.
And put up the Council for Civil liberty to take the case. And there in the court. Was this person.
Defended one of brilliant barrister who's not bumps into. I think you miss a Q.C.
At the time but I wouldn't say for sure. And it's a courtroom that would leave you with barristers.
Middle class women in high hats and spiky gloves and. All the charges eventually were dismissed.
But when the judge for some a nap. He said to the jury. Now I want you to remember.
You are not awarding we were now suing for compensation.
You are not awarding bad jockey or anyone like this you are awarding only an Aboriginal from richer.
We got a few thousand dollars.
Which would never have happened if it were not for the fellowship and the Council for Civil Liberties.
She would leave it there.